un droit tapoche prend le temps de bien
serrer bien pousser le geste précis
guidés par leur professeur encadrant une
quarantaine de lycéens ses appétits
cuisine s'initie aux secrets de la
mousse au chocolat un indispensable de
leur formation professionnelle et plus
encore ça fait partie des recettes qui
doit maîtriser pour l'obtention du crp
notamment réalisé des mousse mousse au
chocolat aujourd'hui ce choix il a été
réalisée simplement parce que les alliés
lors de la libération distribuer du
chocolat à la population voici donc la
note sucrée d'un repas un peu
particulier semblable à ce que l'on
mangé en 1945 une simple dinde farcie et
une jardinière de légumes préparés dans
de nombreuses familles françaises de
l'époque ça me fait bizarre parce que ça
me
comme si tu as me transporter et je
ressens un petit peu ce qu'ils ont
ressenti en mangeant entendre tout ça
accueillis avec le choeur avec amour et
avec plaisir
en début ça allait mais tout le temps
passe et va plus on s'en rend pas compte
c'est stressant presque midi le repas
approche pour ces élèves destinés aux
métiers de la gastronomie c'est un
apprentissage professionnel le moyen
aussi de les intéresser à l'histoire
selon l'enseignante co organisatrice de
ce projet l'autre avec en projet parce
que moi je trouve ça intéressant parce
qu'il les avait demande après par projet
il s'en rappellent toujours comment fut
pas de projet mais qu'est ce qui se
passe ça marque
ils sont actifs ils sont acteurs ils
apprennent point d'orgue de cette
journée parents d'élèves proches et
enseignants de l'établissement ont pu
savourer les plats préparés par les
lycéens